brought to you by The Witcher 3 Wild
Hunt available now hello and welcome to
in two minutes I'm going to be real with
you here I kind of just want to get the
show over and done with this week so I
can go back to slaying more griffons as
you can tell I've been putting quite a
lot of time into The Witcher 3 and
because it's such a big game with a lot
to get to grips with in the opening few
hours I thought I'd put together some
tips and tricks of things that I wish
that I'd known before I got 10 hours
into the game and realized that I'd
wasted a bunch of ability points crowns
and monster brains I hope it helps and a
Thousand pardons to the families of all
the drowners that I've killed you might
notice that you're carrying around
currency called orange and Boren's in
your inventory
that's because merchants only accept
crowns be sure to change your currency
by heading to the Vivaldi bank on
hierarchs Square in novigrad because
believe me it's worth your while the
upgrade skill tree can be a little
intimidating by spending ability points
in this tree here you gain upgrades but
they're not activated unless you put
them into this tree here you can swap
them out whenever you want then go into
this mutagen menu
you drop the mutagens in one of these
slots and if you match the mutagen color
with the ability color then you get a
boost on all of the abilities within
that tree that are of the same color
believe me it does make sense during
combat make sure to dodge out of the way
don't roll while rolling may get you
more distance between you and your foe
it uses up precious stamina dodging
doesn't and it has the added bonus of
looking a bit cooler be clever with your
meditation sometimes if you're swamped
by enemies it's easy to kill a few then
move far enough away that Geralt puts
away his sword then meditate you regain
all of your health and your potions and
bombs get resupplied automatically if
you've got all the stuff in your
inventory so you can return to the fight
if full strength if you can attack from
horseback do it you're more likely to
get a one-hit kill and it's easier to
gallop away from danger be sure to equip
Roche with some saddlebags ASAP in that
way he can carry way more loot for you
speaking of The Witcher 3 doesn't have
an annoying
long animation for looting and
harvesting items so you should spam the
action key to pick up absolutely
everything and I mean everything this is
really important in the early hours as
you can start digging into the hefty
crafting system as soon as possible
finally if you're trying to craft armor
or brew potions and you're missing
something remember to look at your other
items to see if you can dismantle them
for the bits you need dismantled don't
drop is a good rule of thumb you don't
get much money for selling old weapons
and armor but you do get lots of useful
bits and trust me you'll be thankful for
all those little odds and ends later on
down the line
so there's just a few things to bear in
mind while you play The Witcher 3 but
obviously with the game of this scale
there is a lot more to see and do so if
you come across any new tips tricks or
Easter eggs like this awesome pulp
fiction one well bring out the [ __ ] take
the [ __ ] sleeping well guess you'll just
have to go wake him up now war gear make
sure you check them in the comments
section below
I would say that you can find me on
Twitter at Lucy James games but let's be
real here for the next week or so I've
got a plow in world to save I'll see you
next time
you